[THEME MUSIC]
[APPLAUSE]
JASON SPERO: I was
talking to a group
out front while we were
getting set up in the room.
And there's an
interesting balance
to strike between all the
different things that you do.
But I thought I would start,
given the title of the book--
can you help us
with a definition?
You have said "bravery
will set us free."
But can you kick us off with a
working definition of bravery?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
So bravery, to me, it's
not dragon slaying, right?
It's not saving a baby
from a burning building.
Bravery is about joy, joy to do
the things that you want to do.
A perfect example of this is,
basically, a fourth grader
named Ainsley.
So Ainsley lives
in North Carolina.
And it was Princess
Week at her school.
So Ainsley shows up
dressed like a hot dog.
[LAUGHTER]
Right?
Bravery, to me, means
like going to Princess
Week like a hot dog.
JASON SPERO: I also forgot
something in the open.
Raise your hand.
There's a group of
high school students
who are part of a
Girls Who Code club.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yay.
JASON SPERO: I want
to give a shout out.
Thank you all for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
In addition, you make
a compelling case
that women are steered into
this focus of perfection.
You give tons of examples
like the one you just
gave of how this manifests.
I want to start with the
broadest of questions.
How did we get here?
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Yeah, so I think--
what I see happens like on a
playground every single day,
if you go to a
playground, you'll
see what I'm talking about.
You'll see boys will crawl
to the top of the monkey bars
and just jump with their
parents like rooting them on.
And with our girls, we're
like, be careful, honey.
Don't swing too high.
Oh, sweetie, your
dress is dirty.
Come over here.
Let me wipe it off.
Did you just take that toy?
Give it back to her.
So from the time that we
are like 30 months old,
we are being coddled.
We are being protected.
And it often starts in the
name of security, right?
I physically want to protect
my daughter from harm.
And then what happens
is the older we get,
we start getting
addicted to perfection.
And we start giving
up before we even try.
Studies show that
young women in college,
when they declare
a major, if they
get a B instead of an A in
an introductory level course,
they'll drop out.
Whereas boys are like, I got
a B. That's amazing, right?
[LAUGHTER]
And in all this perfectionism,
two things are happening.
One, it's making us unhappy.
Women are twice as likely
to be depressed than men--
twice as likely.
And the third thing is we are
waiting to be perfect to lead.
So when you look--
we celebrate all these
amazing women in Congress.
But we still only have
25% women in Congress--
no new Fortune 500
female CEOs this year.
Don't even get me
started about Main Street
where everywhere
you look, we are
waiting to be perfect to lead.
And I think that bravery
is the antidote to that.
I think bravery will
make us happier,
will make us more
joyful, and thus,
will make us more successful.
JASON SPERO: There
are a lot of women
I know at Google, who I've
already recognized some
in the room, who have been
working their butts off
for a long time
and have achieved
and will continue
to achieve and grow.
But I wanted to ask just
about the difference
between achievement and
striving and excellence, really,
but this concept you
define as being gutsy.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
So Carol Dweck has
this amazing line
that like, if life were
one long grade school,
we would rule the world.
But it's not.
And I think that we get stuck
between this idea of being
a go-getter, which all of us
probably in this room are,
and being gutsy.
Those are two very
different things.
Gutsy means I'm going to
take a risk at something,
and it's probably not
going to work out.
But I'm going to do it anyway.
So like for me, I, my whole
life, was a go-getter.
I went to the right schools,
worked at the right places.
I always, quote, "signed
up for things," but things
that I knew that I
could execute perfectly.
I didn't become gutsy until
I ran for Congress at age 33
against someone who had
been there for 18 years.
And I pretty much had
no chance of winning.
That's when everything
changed for me.
Because before that, I
thought that if I failed,
I would literally break,
that it would hurt me
so much that I wouldn't
be able to recover.
And when I failed at something
and it didn't break me,
I was like, OK, I can
live my life this way.
I can continue to be
a gutsy go-getter.
JASON SPERO: Could you
tell us a little bit
about your journey which
led you to run to Congress
and the things that
happened after that?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, so my
parents came here as refugees.
And I was like the
quintessential good Indian
girl.
You know what I mean?
I did everything that
I was supposed to do.
I went to the right schools.
I got A's.
I didn't get into
cars with boys.
All the things, right?
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't do those.
I lived the perfect Indian girl
life, all in search of a better
me.
A more perfect me would make
a more happier Mom and Dad.
And I also thought that,
well, if I was perfect,
I would be happy and that if I
kept moving through the success
culture and getting
those accolades that it
would make me happier.
And so I graduated $300,000
in student loan debt, right?
I thought I would work at one
of those finance law firms,
and I would pay off
that student loan debt
in like a year or two.
And then I could do what
I really wanted to do,
which was run for office
and be a public servant.
Two years turned into 10.
Then I woke up at age 33 working
as a lawyer on a trading floor,
coming home every day
in the fetal position
to a very large bottle of wine.
I hated my job.
I remember I was
sitting there one day.
And my best friend
Deepa calls me.
And it's funny how
your best friend always
calls you when your life
is like falling apart.
[LAUGHTER]
And I go into this room.
And I just start crying.
And she just says,
Reshma, just quit.
And I was like,
(WHISPERING) I can do that?
And I quit.
[LAUGHTER]
I said, all right.
I'm going to do this.
And I ran for Congress.
I was the first Indian
American woman to run.
I remember the only thing my
friends and I knew how to do
was build a website.
And we built one.
And we raised like $50,000
from Indian aunties
that were just so happy
an Indian girl was
running for office.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was the best experience
of my life, because I was free.
And I got crushed in that race.
I raised like $1.4 million, and
I got like a thousand votes.
Don't do the math.
It was really bad.
I was broke.
I was humiliated.
I felt ashamed.
People felt sorry for me.
And I'm one of those people.
I hate when people
feel sorry for me.
But I was able to
recover from that.
And drink a lot of
margaritas for like a month,
ask my boyfriend who's now
my husband over and over
again, what happened?
What happened?
And then I was
like, OK, I'm alive.
I'm ready for my next fight.
And it changed my entire life.
It's funny.
That experience led me
to start Girls Who Code.
And I didn't even code.
Think about how crazy that was.
But it was because of
the bravery of that race
and not winning it
and it not breaking me
that I thought that I could
actually start something
that I wasn't an expert on.
And I think that's the power
of "Brave, Not Perfect."
That's the power of
letting go of perfectionism
and rewriting yourself and
living a life of bravery.
It opens your life
up to so much.
JASON SPERO: There's
a phrase in the book.
You said, "I'm lost,
but I'm not broken,"
which I think is that
moment of strength that
comes from the losing
that you're talking about.
And you use the word
resilience a lot.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
JASON SPERO: What can
people just-- maybe
bring it back for a minute
to the people in this room.
Where does resilience come
into play in everyday life
for people who might
be in this room today?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, so we all
got to throw out the parenting
books.
I know this sounds
dramatic, but I'm serious.
The way that many of
us have been raised
has just been wrong.
So many of us, our parents
protected us, right?
So if we were bad
at soccer, they
would pull us out and
put us into gymnastics.
They never wanted us to feel
fear or rejection or failure.
They were constantly
trying to protect us.
And so we didn't know what
it was like to, basically,
be challenged.
And many times, many of us,
when we were little girls,
we would walk away
something that
didn't come to us right away.
And we would walk
away thinking, oh,
if math isn't coming to me right
away, I must not be good at it.
And we thought that our
mindset was fixed rather
than we had a growth mindset.
And so I think that we have
to unlearn all of that.
So in the search of our parents
trying to build us confidence,
they killed our
resilience, literally
killed our resilience.
And so many of us
find ourselves in jobs
that we feel eh about
but won't walk away.
We find ourselves in
relationships, quite frankly,
that are broken.
But we're too
scared to walk away.
Many of us were
probably walking down
the street last week and
someone bumped into you.
And you said, I'm sorry, right?
And then you went home and
you're like mad at yourself
for not sticking
up for yourself.
Because we don't know how.
We haven't been taught.
And it's the complete
opposite with our boys.
In the quest to teach
our boys how to be men,
how to be fearless,
how to be risk takers,
how to be tough so they
can survive in this world,
we constantly expose
them to challenges.
We constantly push
them on the edge.
We constantly give
them negative feedback
over and over and over again
to build their resiliency.
And we didn't do
that for our girls,
and so we haven't learned how
to operate in a world that
does not reward perfection.
JASON SPERO: So one of the
things that I tried to gauge
is the right balance of
talking about the book
and talking about
Girls Who Code,
we'll get a chance to
come back to the book.
And you can ask questions
about a lot of that.
I want to pivot for a
moment and talk about--
and there's obviously
a lot of overlap.
Tell us about the girls of
Girls Who Code to start.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Oh, my god,
like how amazing they are?
JASON SPERO: How
amazing they are.
RESHMA SAUJANI: How
JASON SPERO: Because
I've been in the room
for those just tiny little
snippets of this club section,
and there's some here.
But tell us about
not these specific 10
women sitting in the front
row, but the girls of Girls
Who Code.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Here's the thing.
I think that-- so a lot of
our girls, half our girls,
are under the poverty line.
Half our girls are
black and Latina.
And so it's this amazing
mix of young women.
We live in a country
whose schools
are so segregated that
what I wanted to build
was classrooms that
look like America.
Because I thought that
if we actually built
sisterhood together
that we could
build the most amazing
future products together.
And what's powerful is that--
so a lot of our girls
come because their mother
drags them.
Their grandmother drags them.
Their librarian talks about it.
Their parents are just
trying to get rid of them
for the summer to do something.
So they don't walk in
being like, god, I'm
a kick butt coder, right?
They actually have a
lot of insecurities
about their ability.
And this book and
this talk really
started from the
same story I would
hear about how when girls were
first learning how to code,
they basically would call
their teacher over and say,
I don't know what code to write.
And the teacher would
look at a screen,
and she'd see a
blank text editor.
So if she didn't
know any better,
she thought, well, my
student spent 20 minutes just
staring at the screen.
But when she pressed
Undo a few times,
she saw that her
student actually wrote
code and then deleted it.
So instead of saying, hey, look
at the progress that I made,
she'd rather show
her nothing at all.
So when girls actually
learn how to code,
it's as if they've learned
a superpower that opens up
their entire life to doing
things that they thought
that they couldn't
do, to stopping
giving up before they even try.
And I think that that's the
beauty and the power of coding.
Girls Who Code, it's
so much more than that.
There was this powerful
article in the "New York Times"
last week about,
how did we get here?
How did we get to a world
where we had 40% of women
in computer science, where we
had Ada Lovelace, ENIAC women,
Katherine Johnson, to
here, where we barely
can get 18% of our
workforce being female?
And don't get me started on
black and Latina numbers.
How did we get there?
And part of how we got
there was that essentially,
in the 1980s, parents started
giving computers to boys.
And so it became something that
they tinkered, and they played,
took apart.
And so when they came
in the classroom,
it was as if the boys were
coming in with an experience
that the girls didn't have.
And then the girls
started questioning
not their ability
but their perceived
ability in their head.
And they started dropping
out one by one by one by one.
It's never about what we can do.
It's always about
what we think we
can do, that voice in
our head that tells us
that we're not good enough,
that we're not smart enough.
We go very quickly from,
this is hard, to, I suck.
I'm not smart.
I've got to go do
something else.
And that, to me, is the
opportunity of Girls
Who Code right now in that,
we've taught a lot of girls.
Now I got to get you to
believe in yourself so
that when it starts getting
tough, because it always will,
you can stick with it.
JASON SPERO: And I
think one of the things
that you've taught
me is it's not just
about getting someone
and getting them curious
in third, fourth, fifth grade.
But that stick
with it as they go
based on all the social
signals in the first year CS
class in university
and all the things
that come after
that, which I think
connects it back to a problem
we talk about a lot of Google.
Which is, where is that
talent pool so that Google
can shift the gender balance?
So can you talk
just about the Girls
Who Code mission from the
deleting code and the "I
can't do this" at the micro,
but to that 15, 20 year journey?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah,
that's powerful.
Like a story on that when
I was doing my TEDTalk,
one of my friends
who's a CS teacher
was saying, when the guys are
struggling with the assignment,
they'll literally come into
office hours and be like, dude,
the computer's broken.
The computer is broken, right?
And women will come and
be like, I'm broken.
There's something wrong with me.
And this happens all
throughout the pipeline.
And so look, I think last year
this country graduated almost
40,000-50,000 computer
science graduates,
of which 10,000 to
12,000 were women.
We have 500,000 open jobs
in computing and technology.
And so we got a lot
of jobs to fill.
And we're living
in a moment where
40% of America's
breadwinners are women.
So women are putting food on the
table, paying for the mortgage.
So we've got to get
them into these jobs.
Girls Who Code, by the
end of 2019, will have
reached 185,000 girls.
Now, I'm not talking about
tinkering with a little code
and making the
sprite make a square.
I mean actually
teaching girls to code.
There is a difference
between exposure and access
and teaching.
And we need to get
very clear about that
as we're thinking about
how we solve the problem.
So I am confident that
we have enough of you
amazing young women coming
through the pipeline.
Now the question is, are
you going to hire them?
Are you going to hire them?
We know that processes
are so broken.
I face this as a CEO
of an organization.
We can't assume that our hiring
processes are equitable, fair,
and just, especially
when we've had
only one type of person come
through the hiring pipeline.
We have to be intentional
about who we want to see.
And so that's the
work that we're
trying to do at Girls Who Code.
We've launched 300 College
Loops on college campuses,
because the vast majority
of young women who
are majoring in CS on
campuses across the country
are ours, our Girls Who Code.
And so now I've got to make sure
that 50% of them don't drop out
and that college universities
have as broken, sexist,
and racist structures--
I'm sure some of the
women in this room
that have gone through them
before know exactly what I'm
talking about, as do companies.
So we have work to
do there to change
that, to change
that mentality of,
we're just going
to root you out.
And then we need to work with
our companies who, I believe,
are truly committed to this
issue, to say, OK, maybe
we need to stop looking
at the same eight colleges
for the same group of women,
especially in a moment where,
because of the
student loan crisis,
many parents are not
confident to say,
all right, sweetie, go take
$300,000 in student loan debt.
It's all going to be OK.
Things have changed.
And so we have to figure
out they're there.
Do we want to find them?
JASON SPERO: And that's about
finding them and sourcing them
into an interview process.
But you've been pretty vocal.
The interview process
itself is somewhat broken,
something you and I've
talked about a lot.
And then it's something we
talk about a lot in leadership
at Google.
Let's say they get the job.
And they show up.
What is the experience
when they show?
Again, they're fighting
existing structures every step
of the way.
So I think once you nail
your current mission,
I think there's this teaching
Google and our kin, our peers,
how to hire and
support these women
when they've landed at Google.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah,
little things like,
don't have all-male
hiring panels.
Don't have all-male
JASON SPERO: That one
doesn't seem that tough.
RESHMA SAUJANI: That one
JASON SPERO: But
it is that tough.
And we haven't changed.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
But I promise you
that most of our
top companies, they
still have all-male
hiring panels.
When you have two
women on a team,
don't split them up just
to make you feel better.
Keep them together.
We like to complain and
bitch to each other.
You know what I mean?
That's what we do, right?
Let us do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Let's build
sisterhood about this.
And so I think there's
certain basic things that we
would think are obvious by now.
And it's a real question.
Look, a lot of these companies
have been built without us.
And so they're used to
operating in a certain way.
And so while the change
is coming, when we come,
are you ready to change?
It's a real question.
And it can't be
something you feel
like you have to do because
people are telling you to do.
You have to do it because
you really want to do it.
You've got to really want us.
I don't feel comfortable
telling my girls
to go to places that
they're not wanted.
Just don't.
Because I'd much rather them
go build the next generation
of companies.
I'd much rather tell you
to go build the next Google
or Facebook, right?
And I think that part of what
I do feel really good about
is that 90% of our
funders of Girls
Who Code are corporations.
And so I'm believing
the best right now
about people's intentions.
I'm just also
believing that we got
to work a little bit harder and
have real honest conversations
about each other, with each
other, about what's broken
and what's not.
JASON SPERO: I had a great
conversation outside.
And I hope I'm not
sharing too much
from this person who shared.
We talked about
being someone who
had a background in
engineering and applying
to an MBA program, the
role that her family played
in supporting her.
So I want to broaden
off that and ask--
because I've seen it in the
Girls Who Code rooms how
the girls and young women
support one another--
can you talk about
the role of community?
And I mean that from the
clubs to the summer institute
to university, and
then as you just
said, making change from within
a bunch of these [INAUDIBLE]..
How can women
support each other?
RESHMA SAUJANI: I said I
wasn't going to bring it up.
But "60 Minutes" yesterday did
a special on girls in coding.
And they didn't include
any women organizations
as part of it.
And in fact, lifted
up a man to tell
the rest of the 11 million
people watching what we need
to do with women in technology.
JASON SPERO: Reshma got pretty
fired up about this today.
RESHMA SAUJANI: So we knew
this was coming for a year.
And so for a year, we were
talking to the "60 Minutes"
producer saying,
you can't do this.
For too long, women
have been written out.
Our contributions
And all you have to
do is go back about,
read about Ada
Lovelace and the ENIAC
women and Katherine Johnson.
And so they came.
And they filmed our girls,
this amazing Title I
school in Queens, these
young black girls of third
to fifth grade that were showing
the amazing things that they
were doing about robots.
And on Thursday, they
said, you know what?
We cut that out.
I said, all right,
you want to play.
We'll play.
So I wrote a Medium
post last night.
And this is the
thing about bravery.
Bravery doesn't
always feel good.
And I'm sitting there.
And I really want to throw up.
And I was like, I have no
choice but to do what's right
and tell my truth.
And so over the past 24
hours, it's been amazing.
Because our community
women, our male allies,
have all spoken up.
And it has been a shit storm
in like the best possible way.
[LAUGHTER]
And that is the
power of community.
That is the power of women
coming up and saying,
enough is enough.
We won't let you write us out.
We won't, not anymore.
And I think one of the
most powerful things
about the internet is
about the ability for us
to then come together
no matter where
we are to lift each other
up and to say what's right.
JASON SPERO: Related
to that decision
to call out "60
Minutes," can you tell me
about the difference
between "this is hard"
and "I can't do this?"
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, I think
the thing is it is natural
to feel that something is hard
to do and then to feel like
that I can't.
Because I can't feels like
it comes from your ability.
And I think, oftentimes, we
start questioning our ability.
Because athletes,
like athletes often
sit on the edge of
their critical feedback
and their ability.
So there's a coach that is
sitting there and constantly
saying, do it again.
Do it again.
Oftentimes, for
us, because we've
been coddled and protected, we
haven't gotten that feedback,
right?
So we haven't been able to
build our muscles in the way
that we need to
build our muscles.
And so I think we
immediately think
that we're either good
or bad at something.
And that's not the
way that things work.
You have to learn how to
practice and build it up.
JASON SPERO: All
right, yes, please?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I was wondering
if you could go back and tell us
about how you ended up creating
a very successful organization
in something you didn't
even have experience in?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, so
it's one of the things
actually I write about in the
book about this idea of just
starting.
So here I am, day after
election, I'm crushed.
I'm broke.
I'm humiliated.
I've pissed off everybody.
Nobody's calling me
for a job, right?
I am surprised that
I'm still functioning.
And it was very clear to me
that those 10 months of my life
were the best 10 months of
my life and that I was happy.
So I'm like, OK, I'm not going
back to the private sector.
And I said, all right, of
all the things that I saw,
where's the place
that I actually think
that I can make a difference?
And I kept thinking
about those classrooms
that I would walk into where
I wouldn't see any girls.
And I don't know about you guys.
But I always have a job
and then a night hustle,
like the thing that I'm
working on on the side.
And I'm a lawyer, so
I love to research.
So I started just looking at
why are there not women in tech?
Where are the girls?
What are the programs?
And I would spend my lunch
hours and my nights meeting
with people, principals
who taught computer science
classrooms, PhDs who
were trying to understand
this problem, people
who ran nonprofits.
And so two years
in, I was like, OK,
I think I have an
idea about a solution.
And I was like, I'm a
little bit of a marketer.
So I'm like, oh, Girls Who
Code, that's a cool name.
Let me see if it's on GoDaddy.
It was there.
I bought it for like $1.99.
[LAUGHTER]
Sometimes when we have ideas,
we don't tell people about them
because we think
they're not perfect yet.
So I didn't do that.
So when I would meet
people, they'd be like,
what are you working on?
I'm like, well, I got
this idea, Girls Who Code.
And they're like, oh.
My first funder was
actually Google.
It was my friend.
JASON SPERO: I didn't know that.
RESHMA SAUJANI: I don't
even know if you knew this.
It was this guy,
Alex [? Abelin, ?]
who was running community
affairs at Google in New York.
And he had this budget
where he could actually
give $10,000, $20,000 to
different organizations.
So we were at a conference.
And I was talking to him.
And he's like, oh,
my god, I love it.
He actually just
sent me the note.
And he said, you know what?
I think I can find
$10,000 for you.
I'm like, oh, my god, you can?
And so he invested in me.
And then I was like,
oh, I got Google.
So I can do this.
And then I got Twitter.
And then all these
little pieces of dollars
were legitimacy, legitimacy
of this idea that was simply
just an idea in my head.
And then I just went too
far that I couldn't quit.
And I had to just
do one program.
And here we are.
JASON SPERO: You have said that
the perfection cycle is getting
worse .
Can you talk about the role
of social media in perfection?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Oh,
my god, like five
minutes scrolling on Instagram
and your anxiety peaks, right?
It hasn't helped.
I mean, most of us
will take 500 selfies
to take that perfect
selfie, right?
And you'll take one.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like social
media exacerbates
the perfectionism in me.
And then we also think
that all these people,
why am I not happy?
Look at all these
other people that
are living these perfect lives.
And what's wrong with mine?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So outside of Google,
I do a lot of work
with helping high school
students understand
what personal development is.
And so I was just wondering
if you can go back
to high school, what do
you wish that you invested
in yourself more?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Ah,
what a great question.
I wish that I had learned this
whole brave not perfect thing
more.
One of the things I
talk about in the book
is this idea of doing
something you suck at.
So every man I know does
something he sucks at--
golf, tennis,
fantasy, basketball.
President Obama
sucks at basketball
and plays it all
the time, right?
It's like they can do
things that they are not
good at but they love.
We don't have that.
Most of us will not even
go to a Soul Cycle class
till we're "fit," right?
The point of going
to an exercise class
is to get fit, right?
And so I have
started, at 40, doing
things that I'm not
good at but that I like.
I love this Savasana
thing at yoga.
I can't do a headstand,
barely can do a Child's Pose.
And I wouldn't go
to yoga because I
was too embarrassed, right?
Now I do things that I
like, but I'm not good at.
I wish I did that
when I was younger.
I missed out.
I loved gymnastics, but I
couldn't do a cartwheel.
And I still remember that.
I can still feel that feeling
of being in my gymnastics class
and feeling like a jerk
because I couldn't do anything
and just wanting to
run out of the room.
And I wish that I had
just stayed with things
that I was mediocre at that I
enjoyed and knew what it felt
like, knew what it feels like
to be Barack Obama playing
basketball.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASON SPERO: One of the things--
I want to stay with the
questions from the crowd.
But one of the things
that struck me is you also
point out that while it's great
to have a Beyonce or a Venus
Williams or Serena
Williams or whatever it is,
that's also an impossible
standard as well.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Totally.
JASON SPERO: Right?
So when you go out
to do the cartwheel,
you shouldn't be aiming to--
RESHMA SAUJANI: No, you should
be aiming to be mediocre.
You should be just aiming to--
we need more feeling like what
it's like to be mediocre--
JASON SPERO: The story
of my life, by the way.
RESHMA SAUJANI: --not what it's
like to feel excellent, I mean,
not excellent, but like A plus.
AUDIENCE: But they also
started not being good, right?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like Serena
Williams probably sucked.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah.
JASON SPERO: I'm going to
repeat just because somebody
is watching on video.
She said, all the people
that you could name that
are exceptional,
I think, and you
said Serena Williams
started being mediocre
and built their way up
through work and all of that.
RESHMA SAUJANI: It's that
idea of 10,000 hours, right?
If you put enough
time into something,
you can do it "well."
JASON SPERO: Please.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Ishra.
I am very fortunate to
be a middle school club
facilitator and the
club's success specialist
for the organization.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Great.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for all
that Girls Who Code does
and thank you for today's talk.
My question for you is,
can you share your vision
for the clubs for
the next five years?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, world
domination, basically.
[LAUGHTER]
One of the things
that frustrates me--
and we have a report
coming out about this--
is that it's sometimes
said that things
are going great in school.
And that's just not true.
You walk into any
computer science
classroom in the
country, and it's still
80% boys and 20% girls.
And so we use the
clubs as a vehicle
to get girls interested so
that they will then go sign up.
So when you look at the APCS
numbers going up, that's us.
That's us, right?
And I will take credit for it.
Because it's us.
And a lot of it is
because of the clubs.
Because what happens is that
girls get exposed to it,
and they're like, oh, this
is fun making a robot dance
and building this.
It's not as hard as I thought.
And they bring their
friends, and then they
go sign up for CS class or APCS.
And so I would just like to
grow and grow and grow and grow
and grow.
The other thing that
I've been thinking
a lot about is that my
goal this year-- we're
launching international-- is
to start teaching Girls Who
Code clubs at refugee camps.
Because we forget that
half of the country,
they don't have computers.
And that as automation is
changing everything about
the way that we live and work,
we cannot leave half this
country behind.
One of the reasons why
we have so much division
is because far
too many Americans
feel like their
kids are actually
not going to have the same
chance that they've had.
And if we don't
get them exposure
to computational
thinking and computer
science as early
as we possibly can,
they are going to
get left behind.
And we're going to actually have
more division in our country.
So we always like to start
with our clubs, what's
the hardest to reach places?
Where's the poorest
places in our country?
I want to go there.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you so much.
JASON SPERO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I just
wanted to hear a little bit more
from you about when you talked
on throwing away the existing
parenting books and how
I can shift my mindset--
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah,
so much pressure, right?
AUDIENCE: --in raising her
to be different than maybe
what I was raised as.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Yeah, look, I think
that one of the things
that we have to remember
is that we're not with
them all the time.
And there's so many
different people
that they're exposed to
that immediately, culture
plays a huge role in how
we think boys should behave
and how we think
girls should behave.
So I think the important thing
early on is to let them--
it sounds simple, but
let her get dirty.
Stop every bone
in your body when
you see a booger in her
nose to go get a napkin
or when her hair
looks like a mess.
And the thing is, we think
it's a reflection of us.
But it's not.
My son looks like a
pig pen all the time,
and I don't think it's a
reflection of me-- at least,
I tell myself that.
[LAUGHTER]
So let her get physically
messy and also let
her get physically hurt.
You want to see her with
tons of scabs on her knees.
And for her to not--
for you to not--
because I feel like it's--
I was hanging out a
friend this weekend
who has a twin boy and girl.
And the girl hurt her--
her daughter, Jade, is
actually quite bigger
than her son, Tusk.
And we're both reading a book.
And they're both
fighting, play fighting.
And she immediately was
like, Tusky, be careful.
Don't knock your sister over.
I was like, his sister?
She's knocking him over,
and she's twice his size.
But you see what I'm saying.
It is our instinct to go
towards physical protection
of our girls.
Try not to do that.
JASON SPERO: I
would add something
you and I have talked
about is, maybe not at two,
but make them aware of how
much the world around them
is going to send
them signals as well.
They're going to get
it from their media.
They're going get it,
in my family's case,
from their third
grade math teacher.
They're going to get
it from everywhere
that you can't control.
But if can recognize it,
it's so powerful thing
maybe to call it out
that someone else is
trying to put them in a box.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [INAUDIBLE]..
I've been pretty fortunate where
I've had advantages in life.
And one of the challenges that
I face now is that, at times,
the men around me
get very insecure.
And so have you thought
about maybe cultivating
that security in boys growing
up so that they don't feel
like they always have
to be the manly man
and be the sole provider
and stuff like that?
RESHMA SAUJANI: They feel
insecure because why?
Because your talent,
your ability,
or because they feel
like-- what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: So at times,
I've encountered
men who can't cope with
having a female manager.
RESHMA SAUJANI: So I
feel like that is about--
so those are two
different things.
So I think that, when
I think about this,
so I want my son, who is very
like a little mini Gandhi
to feel like he
can be vulnerable.
And he's sweet.
And he's not that tough
rumble guy, right?
And I don't want people to keep
trying to tell him that he's
got to be somebody else.
I do pray on a daily
basis that he does not
become Brett Kavanaugh.
And that is the thing that
I think is an obligation
as a-- right--
is like I got to make sure.
And so he has constantly
surrounded by women.
But the second thing you're
talking about is, I think,
very important.
Which is this conversation
about women in tech,
it's ultimately about power.
We are talking about a
distribution of power.
And we have to be
honest about the fact
that that is not going to
make men feel comfortable.
And also we have
been raised to always
think about prioritizing
men's feelings, right?
And because we've been raised
to be toxic people pleasers,
we have to unlearn that.
So one, we have to stop
caring what they think
and how they feel--
period, full stop, done.
Doesn't matter, right?
And that is a constant thing.
Because we want to be liked.
And then the second
thing is I think
we have to have a real honest
conversation about power,
and we have to activate
our male allies.
One of the best things
that happened last year
was that I was speaking
at the Rochester
Institute of Technology.
RIT had gone from 13%
female to 33% female.
And so I'm speaking at the
Women in Computing group.
And there's these three dudes
that are sitting in the back.
And I'm like, who are you?
And they're like, we're
the men who support
the Women in Computing group.
They had formed a club.
[LAUGHTER]
They had literally
formed a club.
And it was amazing.
And their job was to help
support women to be more brave
or when were
microaggressions were made,
they would say something.
Or sometimes their job
was to just shut up.
You talk about this in our
boardroom oftentimes, right?
It's like men talk 70%
of the time in meetings.
We can't be brave if
they keep talking, right?
So part of it, though,
is being able to have
an honest conversation
with men about this.
So when your leadership
has been questioned,
as I'm sure it has been,
you probably go home,
and you're just mad.
I need you to confront.
And I need us to have the honest
conversations that we simply
need to have with men, and we
have to come from the place
that I think that they
want to do better.
And I'm going to
keep believing that.
I'm going to keep believing that
they are my Rochester Institute
club and that they
want to do better.
And even though post-MeToo
courage has been contagious
for women, we can't assume that
it's been contagious for men.
We can't assume that they know
what to say and what to do
and that they're often not
coming from an authentic place,
which is being able to say
whatever they want to say,
because no one has told
them that they can't.
And so I think it's
an opportunity for us.
AUDIENCE: My question
is not perfect.
RESHMA SAUJANI: I love it.
AUDIENCE: But I'll try.
So I want to hear a little bit
about fighting the existing
structure.
As you said, it's really hard.
Existing companies have
been built without us.
So even like we are at Google.
It's supposed to be
the better ones, right?
But when you look
at the leadership
and when you're sitting in the
meeting room, a lot of times,
it's majority male still.
And I think that
women, they experience
explicit, implicit
[INAUDIBLE] as well as
just the self-doubt as well.
So even at Google,
I've seen women
leaving the workforce
because of this,
or they change teams that
are supposedly better,
or they leave to
another company.
Or they just stay
to fight, right?
So what should we-- what
is, in your opinion,
what is the best kind
of survival defense
mechanism for us in
the existing structure?
And also, at what expense?
So in order for us to
stay here and fight, not
like at Google specifically--
RESHMA SAUJANI:
It can be Google.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
stay here and fight,
but also we need to think about
our mental health as well.
So yeah, what is
the right balance?
RESHMA SAUJANI: So first of
all, I think we have to--
Google's not perfect.
No company is.
Google may be
trying really hard,
and that's awesome, right?
But we still have work to do.
And I think we got
to get to a place
where we can stay and
fight and also acknowledge
the change that needs to happen
and that be OK and not feel
threatened by that or not
feel your personal success
is going to be compromised
if you speak truth to power.
And so that's why, to
me, this book is about,
how do we build our
everyday courage?
You're seeing six women
running for president,
all these men basically
taken down by MeToo.
But still, things happen
to us on a daily basis
that diminish our courage.
And so we can't speak
out at the big moments
because we don't even
know how to stand up
for ourselves anymore.
So we have to start
working on that,
because we have
to stay and fight.
So I think the first thing
is, how do we practice
building our bravery muscle?
How does every time a
microaggression or something
is said in my workplace or
at home or on the street, I
actually speak up for myself?
And we get into the
practice of doing that.
I think the second thing is
is we can only stay and fight
if we have sisterhood
with each other.
How do we support each other?
Every single one of
you that's a manager
should be promoting
someone who is a woman.
You should, period.
And you shouldn't
feel bad about that.
Because the only way we
change the power structures
is if we lift each other up.
You can't have someone
open the door for you
and then you kick
it on the way in.
And so part of it
is understanding
why do we not have
sisterhood with each other.
And I think a lot of that
has to come from the fact
that so many of us have
things that we wanted to do,
whether it was start
a company, go here,
maybe not have a
baby, whatever it is.
And you talked
yourself out of it.
Or someone else
talked you out of it.
And then you see someone
else doing the very thing
that you wanted to do.
And you're left with
regret and envy.
So we have to go
to that place where
our envy is and acknowledge
our deepest dreams.
And then we can
lift each other up.
The third thing is
is I really think
that we have to start having
these honest conversations
with our male allies.
So many men I know--
again, I've been in a room
where a rape joke was made
or something was said
that was inappropriate.
And maybe they laughed
or didn't say anything.
And then they went
home, and they're like,
I can't believe that was said.
They have to be brave too.
It can't just be on us.
It can't just be on
us to change things.
But if we want to make things
different, you've got to fight.
And guess what?
It doesn't always feel good.
But it has to happen,
because it's the only way
that-- nothing will change.
Nothing will change.
And I say that as
someone who is a lawyer.
My law school class
was 50-50% women.
30 years later or
20 years later,
I can go to any law
firm in this country,
and it's still 80%
men and 20% women.
Nothing's changed, because
people don't give up power.
You have to take it.
And you have to ask yourself,
are you ready and willing
to take it?
JASON SPERO: Oh, hello, on the
livestream, what do you got?
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi.
I actually think that the last
couple offered some feedback.
JASON SPERO: Yeah,
we're getting it to.
But fight through.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK, well,
it's imperfect, yes.
I've been fighting a long time.
And it actually is
really, really hard
to build alliances with other
women for exactly the things
that you just mentioned.
I see the envy of most
of my best managers
with the exception
of two people.
And I've been a long-term
contractor in Silicon Valley.
Most of my best
managers have been men.
OK, so I think that's
really unfortunate.
And I'm of an older generation.
I wasn't in the
coddled generation.
And my son was not coddled
because I was a single mother.
So all the things about--
and also, I was a
[INAUDIBLE] kid.
And my mother was
[INAUDIBLE] family.
And I grew up with knees
that have scabs on them
and all of those things.
And so I've been
extremely brave.
And I just have to say
I really want support
from more women,
women in technology.
I still have a whole lot to do.
And I think that what
it is I have a whole lot
to offer as a mentor.
But also I need support
from my younger sisters.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah,
that's so powerful.
You know what?
We just got to keep
working on it, right?
Because so much of this--
I think about my mother.
My mother was always
like, you're too fat.
Stand up straight.
Really, you're going
to apply for that job?
You're not going to get that.
Whereas my father was
like, you can be anything.
You can be everything.
And most of us have
mothers like this.
And it's often because it's
that same perfectionism passed
over and over.
Same dreams deferred, right?
They didn't do the things
that they wanted to do.
They were constantly criticized.
And then we pass it on, and we
pass it on, and we pass it on.
Whereas, oftentimes,
our fathers were
allowed to be brave and
have flaws and thrive.
And so they encouraged
us to do the same.
So we got to break the cycle.
We got to break the cycle.
And I think once you
start acknowledging it,
it can change.
I always say this.
I ran for office twice,
and I lost twice.
But I can celebrate
with my whole heart.
AOC and I took the stage
last Friday together.
And it was like, it was felt
so much joy in watching her,
because at least I tried.
Whereas if I had
never tried before,
I would not be able
to even watch CNN.
It would hurt too much.
So I think if everybody in
this room goes to the place
for your envy is,
where your regret is,
and whatever that is, you
start working on that.
Even if you take one
step, I think your heart
will open up to other women.
I really believe that.
You will become more
generous, because you can.
Because there's nothing there
that you're not trying to do.
JASON SPERO: Just
before you go, I
want to tell the
person who asked
the question on the
livestream thank you.
And also that there was--
you can't see them.
They're not on cameras.
There was a lot of
nodding in the room--
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah,
thank you for that truth--
JASON SPERO: --when you
asked that question.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
--because that's so real.
AUDIENCE: How do
you discern between,
"I am not enjoying this
because I'm not perfect at it,"
and "I am not enjoying it?"
[LAUGHTER]
RESHMA SAUJANI: I think you
got to do it a couple times.
You got to do it
a couple of times
to start getting rid of that
thing of like-- because we tell
ourselves I'm not enjoying
this because I don't like it.
But really, it's because
I'm not good at it.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
think about the threshold,
just like a few times?
Or I went through
a coding class,
and I passed it, gosh darn it.
But I still hate coding.
[LAUGHTER]
RESHMA SAUJANI: But did you
have joy from completion?
AUDIENCE: No.
[LAUGHTER]
I just thought, holy
cow, I'm so glad
I never have to take
this class again.
And I never want to be a coder.
I want to work in
tech, but I'm not
going to sit in front
of a computer all day.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Fair.
Then you passed the test.
It has nothing to do with--
AUDIENCE: It took a long time,
but I think I knew beforehand
that I wasn't in to it.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Well, so I would say.
In this book, I say it's
like the drama wisdom test.
That's why I call it.
OK, so is this your drama
talking where you're saying I
don't like something because you
really just are not good at it?
But it's your
wisdom, which you've
gained from actually trying
it and given it yourself.
And you were like,
I don't like this.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
RESHMA SAUJANI: It's
how I feel about golf.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON SPERO: It's also how I
feel about golf, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So first, I just want
to say I'm really
grateful that we got
to come here and meet
you and everything.
And my question is,
so basically, I'm
one of the founders
for the Girls
Who Code club at our school.
And we have a process
where we basically
have to present in front
of the student council.
And they pass our club.
So we actually had
to go three times.
And the third time
is when our club
got passed, which
seems like not a lot,
but that's really uncommon.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
No, that's crazy.
AUDIENCE: People usually get
passed in the first time,
or they just don't.
But yeah, we kept going.
But a lot of the criticism we
faced was by girls in the room.
When they asked
us, they were like,
why do you need
a Girls Who Code?
Why can't it just
be People Who Code?
Because we don't
have a Boys Who Code,
so why do we need
a Girls Who Code?
RESHMA SAUJANI: And it's
the girls saying it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
It was actually a
girl from, I think,
a comp Sci club, another
comp sci club, saying that.
But we faced a lot of backlash.
And I just want to know.
You probably have
to since the start.
And how do you deal with that?
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Yeah, listen, I think
it's internalized patriarchy.
It is, right?
We oftentimes-- I was just
having this conversation
with a woman last week.
And she was like, well--
she was a senior woman in tech
at a very senior company who
has a son, which I do too.
And she said, I just think we--
what about the boys?
What about the boys?
It's as if we're living in a--
we can talk about the boys when
we're at 70, and they're at 30.
And then I'll start
Boys Who Code, right?
But we're not even close.
We're not even
touching the surface.
I think that's
internalized patriarchy.
I think we're so
raised to be thinking
about them and their feelings.
And I think we so still--
I still remember middle
school teenage freshmen who
wanted to be liked by the boys.
We want them to accept us.
And so in certain ways
by wanting them to accept
us means that we
have to deny things
that are beneficial to us.
We need to have
these conversations.
I'm obviously a
political junkie,
but it drives me nuts,
nuts, that so many women
voted for him.
And that yet again,
they will do it again--
except black women,
except black women.
And what is that about?
But we don't have these
conversations as women.
And we have to.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JASON SPERO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right, hi.
I'm from the same club.
And so as a high school
student, obviously, you
need drive to keep
going forward.
I was just wondering.
How do you find motivation
on day-to-day basis
to take your foundation
to the next level
to do something no
one's ever done before?
Where do you find the
pride and motivation?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Yeah, listen,
I feel like we say in Hinduism.
What's your dharma?
What are you put on
this earth to do?
And I've always had
a very strong sense--
I know this is going
to sound cheesy--
but I love this country.
I love this country.
And I want to do what is best.
And I also know my parents came
here as refugees with nothing.
I've been a dog walker.
I've worked at Baskin-Robbins,
retail, telemarketer.
And I see far too
many of my students
that are just being left behind,
who have like one meal a day
and will go from Oakland
to Facebook or Google
to learn how to code
because they just want
a shot at the American dream.
And I think that I and
we have an opportunity
to make things
different for them.
And so I wake up every
day thinking about them
and about like that I feel so
blessed that I, in my lifetime,
can make one
person's life better.
AUDIENCE: All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Sonia.
I'm also from the same club.
So this is really amazing.
I didn't think that
this would be possible.
But as a high school student,
I find it really difficult
to be motivated to
jump at opportunities
which I'd be scared I'd fail
at and take these risks.
So what inspires you
to wake up one day
and make the transformation
from go-getter to gutsy?
RESHMA SAUJANI: I just
don't want to be--
and I say this.
I'm 43.
I know.
Why am I outing myself?
But I will.
[LAUGHTER]
So I see a lot of women in my
life that are just unhappy,
and they didn't do the things
that they wanted to do.
And they're bitter.
And I don't want to be that.
I don't want to
be sitting there.
That's why I make myself,
once a year, think
about running for office again.
Just to check myself, right?
Because I don't want
to be sitting there
and regret a life never lived.
And that's what also gets me up.
I also feel like--
I think sometimes,
for many of us,
I don't know if I know
what I like anymore
or whether I've told myself
that I don't like something
because I wasn't good at it.
And I don't want to miss out.
I have a husband who lives life
to his fullest, as Jason knows.
And he lives his
life that way, right?
And I see how much
joy it brings him.
You don't see guys like--
this isn't a management book.
Don't read this book if
you want a promotion.
Read this book if
you want to be happy,
if you want to be
joyful, if you want
to live your life with
the full gusto of the way
we should live our lives.
And that's what I want.
And that's what I want for
each and every one of you.
And I think when we do that,
all these leadership numbers,
all this stuff of like
taking the world over--
because I want to do that too--
that's all going to come.
Because we're going to come
at it from a different spirit.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
I'm Eva.
I'm an engineer here at Google.
Thanks a lot for coming
out to speak with us.
I've got a question.
So what advice do you have for
those of us who are in industry
and would really like to make
a connection with the younger
generation of girls that
want to get into coding, that
want to establish friendships,
mentorships, things like that?
There is a typical
check the website thing.
But just kind of beyond that,
do you have any thoughts
on how to get involved?
RESHMA SAUJANI: You should be
giving back every single day.
And you should judge
yourself for that.
You really should, seriously.
And I actually think that--
I mean, I don't
know you, but I'm
sure you have an
incredible story.
And so much for them, they just
want to hear how you did it.
Like, what did you--
what are the doubts that
you had in your head?
What's the knowledge
that you shared?
You have to understand.
So much of, I think, power
and success, as I've realized,
is knowledge sharing.
Even if you told them, hey, when
you go into a Google interview,
this is what to expect.
This is what they're
going to ask you.
These are the tricks
and trades, right?
This is the things
that I doubted.
Don't do this, or do this.
Sharing knowledge,
you have knowledge.
All of us in this
room have knowledge.
You got here.
This is one of the hardest
companies in the world
to get through,
and you got here.
Share that secret
sauce with all of them
and the thousands of others.
Because that's what men do.
They are constantly
sharing information.
We hold our stuff tight, right?
We hold ourselves back
because half the time,
we don't even think
we belong here, right?
We don't even think
we belong here.
So we don't share our knowledge.
And we say, I don't know.
I was just lucky.
Ah, somebody let me in.
But you got here.
So share your knowledge.
Share it.
Share it far and wide.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JASON SPERO: We've got two more.
Thank you for hanging
in, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Simone.
And I, like yourself, changed
my career just recently.
And I just want to know if
you have any advice for me
that I am starting again?
I'm not going to do doubt again.
I'm not in high school anymore.
So do you have any advice
on how can I go about
to learn and grow in technology
without getting myself
in too much debt?
RESHMA SAUJANI: Without getting
yourself into too much debt?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RESHMA SAUJANI:
Part of it is just,
I think, continuing
to try things
and to not doubt yourself.
So how does that work?
So one of the things
we didn't get to,
I want to get to
real quick is, how
do you build a bravery mindset?
We're in California.
Y'all spend a lot of
time drinking green juice
and thinking about what
to do with your bodies.
Let's talk about your mind,
because I think it's just
important to practice our mind.
And meditation is one practice.
I've built another
practice, which
I think is really important.
And that's why you don't
have to take another class
and do another thing.
Because we always think we
have to take another class
to get another skill to-- no.
Don't take anymore classes.
You're good enough as you are.
You are good enough as you are.
But we have to start
practicing things
to get us on the bravery side.
So the first thing is, is you
can't be brave if you're tired.
You can't be brave
if you're tired.
You got to sleep more.
You got to meditate.
You got to get to the gym.
And you got to stop putting off
those doctor's appointments.
You've got to take
care of yourself.
Oftentimes as women, we
put everybody else first,
and we put ourselves last.
And we have to take
care of ourselves.
Second thing, I think
that's really important
is to practice imperfection,
whatever that means for you.
For a lot of women, I say
to them, you know what?
Send an email with
a typo in it--
no emojis, no
explanation points.
Just say what you want
to say and press Send.
And if it's got a
typo in it, who cares?
Nobody cares.
They're too focused
on themselves
to focus on you and
your email, right?
So part of that is
just get whatever
imperfection means for you.
It might mean
store-bought cookies
at your kid's birthday party.
Maybe not in California, but I
was going to say in New York,
it might mean going
to the grocery store
without a full face
of make up on, right?
Whatever that means for
you, practice imperfection.
I think the third
thing is just start.
And that means identifying,
what's your [INAUDIBLE]??
What's the thing that
you are the scaredest of,
the thing at night
you think about
and just, ah, it scares me?
I can't do that.
Start.
Take one step towards that.
For me at Girls Who Code,
it was buying the URL.
For some people, it
might be if you're
thinking about your
fitness, it might mean just
going for a walk tonight.
Or if you're looking
an apartment that
needs to be clean, one shelf.
Whatever it is, just start.
Take one step.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I'm software
engineering at Google.
Thank you very much
for the talk today.
I just wanted to ask about--
do you have any advice for men?
How can men help?
[APPLAUSE]
RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank
you for that question.
I always say.
It's never been a better
time to be a woman.
And I feel that way so
much because there's
men like Jason and Nahal and
you and extraordinary men
in our space right now.
40% of Girls Who Code's
teachers are men.
Half of my board is male.
And I think, how do
we get to a place
where we can really
activate our male allies?
And I think, like I just
said, I do think part of it
is start a club.
Literally start a club,
because none of this
really changes until women
become 30% of the technology
workforce.
And we've got some ways to go.
So in the end, it's
going to be up to you.
We can't always stand
up and fight the fight.
Sometimes we need you
to fight the fight
and to do what's right
and to create the world
that we want you to create.
And so if Google does still
have all-male hiring panels,
I would love for you to
say something about that.
I would love for
you to be the one
to advocate for the company.
You're spending more resources
on teaching girls how to code.
I would love for you
to commit, every time
you hear a microaggression
said or something that's
very blatant, for
you to be like,
hey, that's not right,
and not always rely
on us to be the ones.
Because it's exhausting.
Isn't it, ladies?
It is exhausting.
And so if you can stand up
arm-in-arm in solidarity
with us to create the world that
I think you want to build too,
I think we'll solve this
problem much faster.
JASON SPERO: All right.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank you.
JASON SPERO: Thank
you for the question.
I'm going to--
[APPLAUSE]
In an hour of sound
bites, thank you so much.
I want to tell you.
I read the book as a
father of daughters.
I read the book as a manager
who wants to be better
and I hope as a bit
of a change agent.
And it helped me on
all of those fronts.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank you.
JASON SPERO: I want to
thank you for being here.
My favorite chapter is called
"Brave is the New Black."
Please join me in
thanking Reshma.
RESHMA SAUJANI: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]